let's start in the NFL Cam Newton making
the rounds doing some media not playing
football these days he was on The Late
Late Show with James Corden this week
never seen an episode was that necessary
I mean you're not a fan or I'm not a fan
I mean listen carpool karaoke is not
gonna pull me in and is the accent funny
I don't think so
clearly faking it I don't know much
about him to be honest I don't I don't
watch it I don't follow it I wouldn't
say I'm against him but would I ever go
on that show wouldn't waste my time Wow
yeah well Cam Newton disagrees and he
surprised the audience by telling them
that he's given up sex for March not
just sex not just sex and this is the
way he said it too which was very
strange he said I hope this is an adult
crowd looks like it is no climax so
there's no climax that that's the thing
that was the way he said it so then I
interpreted that it's not just sex but
you know no gratifying yourself listen I
don't often talk about my religious
beliefs on the air but sex makes you
weak all right if you touch yourself
below the waist weakness okay I don't
have a name for my religion but I know
that if I go if I go a week or two I can
lift up a car I don't often do it you
know I mean I don't feel the need but
but I think not not having sex or not
releasing your demons as my mom would
call them if you don't release your
demons then it makes you now you get
more focused you know what I mean you
got more energy you can do more in
prison the guys who get like super
jacked and all about weights they don't
they don't touch themselves because they
are they would they want to lift my
weight I'm sitting I'm like an image of
her yelling up like Anthony you're not
releasing your demons up there are you
it's not an impression of my mother
because I mean I don't know what voice
voice you think that is
but it's not a woman's voice it's
certainly not my mom's and you've met
her and you know she listens yes she
would yell that all the time I couldn't
take a shower without her just banging
on the door like like there was a fire
and I knew that something was up I knew
that that my body he's not my body that
it belongs to God and I shall not
desecrate I shall not desecrate him by
by letting my hands wander you Catholics
are weird no I would this has nothing to
do with Catholicism this is more like a
government thing here's one be like Mike
Pence like Cam Newton like believes in
this stuff though there's a lot of
athletes you were said you were saying
that in in prison that they believe that
this is on it's all weird sort of not
backed by science conspiracy nonsense it
is it is backed by science I'll tell you
this I once read an article in a
magazine about how doctors in the ER
I'll have to do like 24 hour shifts how
they stay awake
they'd have different like little tips
one of them was like you pound a cup of
coffee and then take a nap for like five
minutes so when you wake up the
caffeine's kicked in and you're like
ready to go the last guy last guy was
like I don't know if this works for
women but it works for men he goes you
touch yourself until you were just about
the climax and then you stop and that
keeps you awake that like gives you like
a burst of energy and you can go about
your day he goes but if you go too far
if you don't have if you don't have the
expert touch that I have and you go too
far then he's like you're done he's like
go home because you are not going to
save any lives that day so I give it up
to Cam Newton I would say this makes the
Panthers the favourites to win it all
this year thirty days without I know for
Greg that's like that's pretty normal
and I know I know your wife is never
once never once climaxed she is the
strongest person and she's like an aunt
she can lift a hundred times her own
weight I found it very interesting that
it was like a offseason challenge that
he made for himself that each month Cam
Newton was gonna give up different
things so January it was gambling
she's interesting as an NFL player
February was meet and then March was not
only sex but Wi-Fi I mean I I feel like
giving up Wi-Fi for a month is a lot
tougher than if you're not gonna ask
your baby what do you need Wi-Fi for
where you check your email no who cares
I see this is why I think that the NFL
is unfair and that it really is a
player's league you know people show up
to watch the players but let's see
Robert Kraft do this let's see Robert
Kraft got 30 days this guy can't even
get to the airport without without
pulling over and in climaxing demons
everywhere
Robert Kraft that was a good when it was
more fun than I thought we'd have a
night Papa John's is hoping that
Shaquille O'Neal can help fix the PR
backlash that they've had ever since the
actual Papa John had to leave the
company because he said the n-word Shack
among his many endorsements has now
decided to join Papa John Board of
Directors and he's gonna own it's the
funniest thing to me and they would be
like okay we got this scandal where our
owner used the n-word
on a conference call we had to let him
go how can we assure this never happens
again
who's the biggest black guy we know
let's get him in here and ensure that
everything is tip-top from here on out I
don't know how bad Papa John's business
suffered when when Papa dropped a nun
bomb on a conference call but I got to
think there are some people who like
switched over
I got a think there's some people in
this country who've never eaten pizza in
their lives so we're like we got to
support this guy and you know what I
hope they're not listening because I
hate you
but I do like Shaq Shaq is obviously he
endorses a lot of things but he's very
particular you know what I mean he's not
gonna endorse just any insurance company
it's gonna be the general right but does
this mean you think that that like what
is the general hiding like what are
these other companies that he endorsed
oh he's a piety he's a Confederate
General I mean he's hiding quite a gold
bond
educated powder they had their run-ins
with slavery that Carmen ham was
basically built gold bond um so I was
basically built on slavery that's what
the bond in gold bond comes from I see
how it was just like used for torture
mm-hmm mm-hmm if you see Amistad you'll
know what I'm talking about
but getting Shaq in there I think solves
all their problems
I mean he's on the board he's not just
like he's not just endorsing he's not
pulling a Payton he's not pulling a
Peyton Manning he is on the board making
decisions about Papa John's Pizza and
you can bet they're non racist decisions
not like before now the most racist
pizza chain is Domino's and then Pete
and then Pizza Hut but but I think that
in Little Caesars of course is beyond
the pale Little Caesars does not believe
the Holocaust happens exactly that's why
that's all he talks about that and if
you look at their ovens they're modeled
after they're modeled after much of the
Holocaust but that is that's how we're
gonna keep you updated on on the world
of pizza can you just imagine what those
board of director meetings what it would
be like they're like well what are you
what do you think Shaq is the expansion
into the Southwest racist like what's he
doing at these meetings oh yes it's very
racist that's my impression of Shaquille
O'Neal that's pretty good it's very
racist Chuck
you
[Music]